youngest parts are the oldest, meaning they held the wisdom. So like I'm 46, so my six year old self is 40 years old. If that math doesn't make sense to you because it's emotional math, it's inverse math in the sense that your six year old has been in the car for the last 40 years.
最年轻的部分其实是最古老的，这意味着它们承载着智慧。比如我今年46岁，那么我6岁时的那个自我现在已经40岁了。如果这种数学逻辑让你觉得费解，那是因为这是情感数学，从某种意义上说它是反向数学，因为你6岁时的那个自我已经在车里坐了40年了。
Yeah. So when I start talking to the six year old, as if they are, you know, equals and, and, or like, you know, I want to learn from you. I, I understand that you've been here longer. If they're behaving like they are six or like have those six-year-old needs and stuff like that, then we want to structure the system and somewhat like where's the today you, where's the future you, how can we kind of create that? And so when we're talking temporal space and time, we have to help people be able to create past, present, and future of them because a lot of themselves don't know what's going on and
是的。所以当我开始和那个6岁的自我对话时，就像对待平等的人一样，或者说，我想向你学习。我理解你在这里待的时间更长。如果他们的表现像6岁孩子，或者有那种6岁孩子的需求之类的，那么我们想要构建一个系统，比如现在的你在哪里？未来的你在哪里？我们该如何创造这种状态？所以当我们谈论时间空间和时间时，我们必须帮助人们能够创造出他们的过去、现在和未来，因为他们内心很大一部分并不知道发生了什么，
who's what and where. It's what waits underneath the mouse, beneath the bruises you stop looking at. All right. Welcome to the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast. I'm here with Adam O'Brien of the Wounded Healer Institute. And I am so, so glad to finally connect. I've sat down to write this email starting two years ago when I started hearing about your work from people and genuinely meant to.
谁是什么，在哪里。这就是潜伏在鼠标之下、潜伏在你不再注视的伤痕之下的东西。好的，欢迎来到Taproot Therapy Collective播客。我和Wounded Healer Institute的亚当·奥布莱恩（Adam O'Brien）在一起。我真的、真的很高兴终于能联系上。从两年前我开始从别人那里听说你的工作时，我就坐下来准备写这封邮件，而且是真心实意的。
And every time I would start to touch the keyboard, my life would blow up and the building would be up for sale and you would be trying to buy it or you know meteors would fall out of the skies so luckily I'm not a behaviorist and I didn't have laviantly conditioned me to stop trying to connect with Adam and I'm really glad that we finally are connecting so thank you so much for being here and I'm wondering if you we finally are connecting. So thank you so much for being here and I'm wondering if you can kind of introduce some of the the work that you're doing and the tensions that you're diagnosing in the industry that are a lot of the same tensions
但每次我刚要触碰键盘，我的生活就会炸开，大楼要被出售，你又要试图买下它，或者你知道流星会从天而降。所以幸运的是，我不是行为主义者，我没有被条件反射训练到停止尝试与亚当联系，我真的很高兴我们终于联系上了，所以非常感谢你能来到这里，我想知道你是否可以介绍一下你正在做的工作，以及你在行业中诊断出的那些紧张关系，这些紧张关系和我们在这里谈论的很多紧张关系是一样的。
that we talk about on here. Yeah great yeah thank you for for having me and extending the invite and the the backdrop there is is pretty heartwarming in a lot of ways. So I'm definitely interested to branch out into what you're doing as far as what I'm doing. So the Wounded Healers Institute came as an idea of, if people are, if not everybody is diagnosable, then what are people doing for their mental health? Like what are they doing for their physical health? And a lot of my kind of dynamic of like, so one of my private practices is called mutual arising. And it's a Taoist concept, but has a familiar kind of context within Buddhism of dependent origination. And when I look at dependent
太棒了，谢谢你邀请我，背景听起来在很多方面都很暖心。所以我绝对有兴趣扩展到你正在做的事情，至于我正在做的事情。Wounded Healer Institute的构想是，如果不是每个人都能被诊断出疾病，那么人们在心理健康方面都在做什么？就像他们在身体健康方面做的那样？我的一种动态模式是，我的私人诊所之一叫“相互生起”（mutual arising）。这是一个道家概念，但在佛教中也有类似的“缘起”背景。当我审视缘起，以及那个“依赖”这个词和那种成瘾性，就像硬币的两面一样，我试图把世界理解为它的镜像对立面。那么，心理健康健身房的镜像对立面会是什么呢？比如，我们能有一个心理健康的中间地带，在那里我们可以进行这些对话吗？
origination and that dependence word and that addiction and like kind of both sides of the coin type of thing, I was trying to understand the world as it's like mirror opposite. So what would be the mirror opposite of like a mental health gym? So like, can we have like a middle ground of mental health where we can have these conversations
病理学的界限在哪里？所以我的论文和学术研究确实引导我试图理解，创伤、解离和成瘾之间似乎确实缺失了一种动态关系。当我们从整体上看这个系统时，我们倾向于把药物成瘾放在一边。你知道，DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）正在寻找证据，证明存在过程性成瘾，比如饮食失调，还有不同的
and where does the line of pathology? So my dissertation and my academic research really led me to try and understand that like, there's a dynamic between trauma dissociation and addiction that really seems to be missing. And when I look at the system as a whole, like we kind of put drug addiction over there. And you know, the DSMs are, you know, finding evidence that there's like process addictions and there's like, you know, eating disorder and, you know, there's different
界定所有这些事物的方式，但我从未对这些定义感到满意。然后在2012年左右，他们开始提出定义，即成瘾是一种可治疗的疾病。我并不反对疾病模型。作为一个定性思维者，我确实从经验上想知道我们所说的这些词是什么意思。我想知道意义、方式和原因，这引导我到了一个点，
ways of framing all of this stuff, but I've never been satisfied with the definition. And then around 2012, they started coming out with definitions that, you know, addiction is a treatable disease. And I'm not against the disease model. I do as like kind of empirically kind of want to know what we mean by those words as a qualitative thinker. I kind of want to know the meaning and you know, how and why's and my, you know, it's kind of led me to a point where
我希望能与更多人进行一次广泛的对话。我认为其中存在一些普遍性。我的研究强调成瘾是跨诊断的。我们刚刚确定了这一点，你知道，在2022年，我引用了一篇文章，解离刚刚被确定为跨诊断的。所以我提出的论点是，在成瘾框架内的诊断方面，我们确实遗漏了一些东西，以及它如何与这个跨诊断的世界相关联，以及所有这一切之下是什么，
I kind of want to have a general conversation with more people. I think there's some universals there. My research highlights that addiction is transdiagnostic. We just identified that, you know, in 2022, I cited an article that the dissociation was just identified as transdiagnostic. And so I'm making the argument that we do have some things that we're missing as far as diagnoses within the addiction framework and how it relates to this trans diagnostic world and what's underneath all of this
而不仅仅是关于“你感觉如何”的表面答案，而是关于你身上到底发生了什么，以及从创伤知情护理到现在的转变，我认为解离确实就是创伤。这意味着我们所看到的PTSD症状，在我看来基本上就是在描述解离。所以这里面有很多内容。我会给你几个切入点，看看你对什么感兴趣。我的意思是，我认为解离和成瘾之间的重叠是
and not just the surface level answers of how are you feeling, but like what's really kind of going on with you and that transition from trauma informed care to now I think dissociation, it really is trauma. Meaning that everything that we look at to me as far as the symptoms of PTSD are basically describing dissociation. So there's a whole lot there. I'll give you a couple jumping off points and see what's interesting to you here. I mean, one of the things I think is that the overlap between dissociation and addiction is something that
我认为现在一些治疗成瘾的顶尖人才开始独立注意到的事情。所以当许多在某方面非常有效的人同时注意到这一点时，我认为行业应该关注它，并可能将其视为一种预研究指标，一种客观的衡量标准，看看什么有效？预研究，我们称之为定性与定量。是的。你知道，这对我来说突显了我在左右脑过程之间所做的工作，以及谁会给什么贴标签？如果你是一名医生，你是在给所见之物贴标签，并命名症状，PTSD也是一样，你基本上只是在重申客户所说的话，并发现这里存在一些主题。但如果我们说
I think some of the best people treating addiction now are starting to notice independently. So when a lot of people that are highly effective at doing something start noticing it at the same time, that's something that I think the industry should pay attention to and maybe treat as a sort of pre-research the industry should pay attention to and maybe treat as a sort of pre-research indicator objective type metric of what worked? Pre-research, we're going to say qualitative versus quantitative. Yeah. You know, and that to me highlighted in my work between right brain, left brain processes, and who would label what what? If you're a doctor, you're labeling what you're seeing and you're naming the symptoms same thing with like PTSD, you're just basically reiterating what the client has said and you're finding that there's like themes here. But if we're going to say that like
预研究，因为我认为这很危险，特别是对于你知道的，我是一个长期康复的人，我认为我们说定量与定性研究之间存在等级制度是很危险的，我真的认为我们是分开但平等的，不是分开的，而是平等的。从定性上讲，如果有人做过心理学方面的定性测试，我知道社会学、市场营销和公关之类的东西，但如果我们诚实的话，
pre research, because I think it's dangerous, especially with you know, I'm a person long term recovery, I think it's dangerous for us to say that quantitative versus qualitative research that there is a hierarchy here, I really see that we are separate and equal, not separate, but equal. And qualitatively, like if somebody had done a qualitative test as far as psychologically, like, and I know that like sociology and marketing and PR type of stuff, but if we were to be an honest
事后看来，我想象每一个在成瘾领域工作的人都会说，是的，非成瘾性阿片类药物，你怎么能那样做？那不是自相矛盾吗？谁在把关？谁在保护那种广告？或者那种定性，你知道，也许他们有定量或者对他们来说意味着什么的任何东西，但定性叙事中确实有一些东西，我们应该保持我们的“胡扯探测器”，因为那些有定性生活经验的人，
in hindsight, I'm imagining that every, in hindsight, every person was working in the addiction field is like, yeah, non addictive opiate, how can you even do that? Like, that's an oxymoron? Who was who was guard? Who was, you know, who was safeguarding that kind of ad? Or that type of qualitative, like, you know, and then they maybe they had the quantitative or whatever that means to them, but like, there's something about the qualitative narrative that we should just kind of have our like, you know, our BS button to be like, because those who have qualitative lived experience,
你知道，不是预研究，对吧？对我来说，必须给予它比那种探索事物然后深入到核心的东西更高的价值，它们都有价值。什么是更被支持和/或，你知道，有效性，它是什么，它更被支持和/或被相信。
you know, isn't pre-research, right? We have to give that more value to me than it being like this kind of like exploring things and then kind of getting down to a nitty gritty, like they're both valuable. What is just more supported and or, you know, validity and being what that is, it's more kind of supported and or believed.
我认为我们现在进入了一个非常有趣的时代，特别是随着詹姆斯·韦伯望远镜以及关于起源和大爆炸的所有事情，你知道，先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题，我们仍然在进行那种对话。而且一些正在显现的现实似乎表明，精神上的解决方案和/或答案，以及我们拥有的一些伟大的思想家，正在得出同样的结论，即这就是，你知道，众所周知的上帝体验。观察者和被观察者之间没有分离。
And I think we're now entering in a very interesting age, particularly with like the James Webb telescope and the whole stuff with, you know, the origins and the Big Bang and like, you know, what came before chicken or the egg type of thing, we're still in that conversation. And like some of the realities that are coming through seems that the spiritual solutions and or answers and a lot of the great thinkers that we've had are coming, you know, to the same conclusion that like, you know, this is, And a lot of the great thinkers that we've had are coming to the same conclusion that like, you know, this is, you know, the proverbial, you know, God experience. And there is no separation between the observer and the observed.
是的。我的意思是，我非常同意你的一点是，定性和定量研究，两者都是平等的，应该得到更多的支持。但第二点，我不知道我们试图做出的那种区分是否真的很大。很多人会谈论定性研究，如果研究人员注意到，
Yeah. I mean, I, I, a lot there. I mean, one of the things that I totally agree with you on is that the qualitative and quantitative research, one, are both kind of equal and should be more supported. But then two, I don't know that there's a huge distinction between those like we try and make. A ton of people will talk about qualitative research and it's like if a researcher notice,
如果临床医生在房间里注意到他们尝试了15种方法，其中一种让80个人康复了，而另一种效果没那么好，然后他们写了一篇定性研究，那是完全定性的吗？因为它开始于，我的意思是，是的，你做得对，你做一个随机对照试验来检查偏差，而不是为了创造经验主义，你知道。嗯，确实，但我认为，当我们进入到我工作的动态和哲学层面时，特别是这种消除隐性偏见，听起来很像消除疾病。
if a clinician notices in the room that they try 15 things and one of those things gets 80 people well and the other one is not as effective and then they write a qualitative study is that Completely qualitative because it starts off I mean, yeah You do it right you do a randomized controlled trial to check for biases not to not to create empiricism, you know Well true but I think you know when we kind of get into the To me the dynamics and the philosophicals of my work particularly like this implicit removing implicit bias sounds a lot to me like removing disease
是的，我对此非常谨慎，因为我们作为创伤领域的工作，你知道，而且了解你所做的，隐性系统确实是我们真正谈论的，因为任何在生命后期出现的复杂问题通常都发生在三岁之前。这些是我们的隐性系统。我们的隐性系统就是我们的右脑。它是我们的感受。从某种意义上说，我们听别人给我们贴标签听得太久了。所以我做了这个小小的思想实验：什么是理性的？如果那是理性大脑给情感贴标签的方式呢？嗯，我认为这就是为什么一些荣格深度心理学的人谈论
Yep, and I'm very cautious of that because of our work as a trauma, you know And you know knowing what you do as well like the implicit system is where we're really talking about because any complicated, any complicated issues that are presenting later in life usually have happened before the age of three. And these are our, it's our implicit system. Our implicit system is our right brain. It is our feelings. We have been, we've been listening to somebody else label us for too long in that sense. So I do this little thought experiment of like, is what is irrational? What if that is a rational brain's way of labeling emotional? Well, I think that's why some of the Jungian in-depth guys talk
隐喻的真理，你大脑中有一部分不是用语言思考的，但它仍然用意义思考，而那种更大的意义必须被过滤成语言，在它无法完全契合的地方，是通过符号。它是通过隐喻，通过情感宇宙学，你知道。对，但语言的符号以及谁在使用它，所以这就是我们开始进入解离效应的地方，比如我们作为临床医生，能够知道是谁在说话，取决于他们构建它的语言，或者它所呈现的发展年龄。这就是我们能够看到的方式。而且，一旦你把解离看作一种发生的现象，你就无法再忽视它了。是的。
about the truth of metaphor is you've got a part of the brain that doesn't think in language but it still thinks in meaning and one of the ways that that greater meaning has to be filtered into language where it can't quite fit is through symbol. It's through metaphor, it's through emotional cosmology you know. Right and the symbols of language and who's using it though so that's where we start to get into the dissociative effect of like us as clinicians being able to kind of know who is talking dependent upon the language in which they are framing it or the age, developmental age that it is being presented. This is how we're able to see. And, you know, once you see dissociation as a phenomena of happening, you can't unsee it. Yeah.
你开始在所有事情中看到它。这是一种，你知道，无论那种效应叫什么，或者其他什么。但它确实是那些强有力的事物之一，真正告诉我们我们在这里有所发现。我愿意在法律上说，我可以知道人们是否都在那里，从这个意义上说。你知道我的意思吗？如果他们的表现好像他们都在那里，而且你知道怀疑和/或需要经验证据的细微差别，证据就是我们在这里，或者情绪是真实的，但如果你感觉不到它们，并不意味着它们不存在。完全正确，而且很多我非常怀疑的疗法，
And you start to see it in everything. And that is a, you know, whatever that effect is called or whatever. But like, it is one of those powerful things that really tell us that we're onto something here. And I am willing to legally say that, like, I can know if people are all, all there or not, in that sense. You know what I mean? If they're acting as if they are all there and you know The nuance of doubting and or needing empirical evidence Like the evidence is that like we are here or that emotions are real But like if you can't feel them that doesn't mean they don't exist Exactly and a lot of the therapy that I'm very skeptical of
我非常怀疑的，比如对CBT的滥用，绝对是ABA疗法，你并没有真正考虑到孩子的体验，你只是考虑到其他人的体验。我觉得他们所做的是通过让人解离来关闭情绪，这样对系统或家庭来说更容易。仅仅因为你创造了这种客观指标，
like that I'm very skeptical of, like misappropriations of CBT, definitely ABA therapy where you're not really taking into account the child's experience, you're just taking into account other people's experience. I feel like what they're doing is turning off emotion by making someone dissociate so that that is easier for the system or easier for the family. And just because you've made this kind of objective metric
你试图治疗或你创造的症状下降了，并不意味着那个人内心没有在尖叫，这对我作为临床医生来说仍然是一个问题。嗯，熟练的解离，对吧。我们只是在教这个吗？但我们确实必须稍微玩弄一下解离效应。
that you're trying to treat or the symptom as you create it come down, that doesn't mean that the person's not screaming inside, which is still a problem for me as a clinician. Well, skilled dissociation, right. Are we just teaching that? But we do have to play around a little bit with the dissociative effects.
所以我的研究强调的是，存在一个规范范围，不一定是我的工作强调了这一点，但那些有解离体验和/或现象的人，比如作为自我的部分，他们仍然可以体验到正常的解离范围，比如开车时走神。但我的意思是，他们完全有能力。所以当我们，我会和你做一点我的演讲，因为尊重你给出的答案，它们不一定是技巧，但它们确实很有趣。所以，我如何理解，我认为我希望某人带走并思考一段时间的主要状态，我的意思是，任何我所说的，我希望如此，但这一条对我来说是深刻的，即物理身体就是心理潜意识。除了通过观念和/或分离之外，没有分离。所以存在一个终极现实，我们都在这里。我们都在一起。我们都是一体的，在某种微观世界中，事物之间的空间不是虚无。是的，理性大脑认为一加一等于二，当我们开始进入CBT，比如一加一等于二，当我们开始进入CBT，比如一加一等于二，就像该死，这是一个关于，好吧，如果我向你证明一加一在合理怀疑之外等于三呢？
So what my research kind of highlighted is that there is like a normative range has been not necessarily my work has highlighted this, but like people who have dissociative, you know, experiences and or phenomena as like, you know, parts of self, they experience, they can still experience the normal range of dissociation, like, you know, driving a car and kind of getting lost in that. But I mean, they're fully capable. So when we, and I'll kind of do a little bit of my spiel with you because and you know, respectful of the answers that you give that like, they're not necessarily supposed to
如果我能在现实世界中向你证明在合理怀疑之外，一加一等于三，你会不会冒个险，相信也许还有其他答案？所以一加一，甚至一乘以一，都等于三。我们必须开始定义我们所说的这些词以及它们的生活体验。那么你能为那些刚上完第一门研究入门课的临床心理学学生举一个更具体的例子吗？
be tricks, but they are kind of fun. So you know, and how I've come to understand and I think like the main state that I would want somebody to walk away with and like think about for a while I mean, you know, anything that I kind of say I hope that but like this one is the one that's profound to me is that the physical body is the psychological unconscious. Separated others other than through idea and or you know separation So there is an ultimate reality that we are we are all like here. We're all together. We're all like one in some type of you know Microcosm of like the space between things is not absence. Yeah right the rational brain as like one plus one equals two when we start to get into the CBT like one plus one equals two, when we start to get into the CBT, like one plus one equals two, like only shit, it's a matter of like, okay, well, how about if I prove to you that one plus one equals three beyond a reasonable doubt?
他们会在这一集播出后给我发邮件说我不应该拥有执照。直接对他们说吧，因为他们就在那里。他们在听。好的。所以你的意思是，你认为我必须给他们答案？不，只是让那个概念更具体一点。嗯，这更多是因为我觉得这会很有趣，而不是你知道的。所以至于答案，我的意思是至于解离光谱，是我正在看的。所以当我们看它的光谱时，我们发现了病理学，我们也发现了规范范围。如果规范在给病理学贴标签，那么病理学会给规范贴什么标签呢？我认为很多艺术家和很多人已经做过足够多的这种事情，以至于我们可以看到他们对规范的看法。如果我们要做正常的，比如，好吧，一加一等于二，那是我们生活的现实。那是事情加起来的时候。通常当人们说事情加不起来时，他们会说这是不合理的，或者那个答案有什么问题，对吧？
If I can prove to you that beyond a reasonable doubt in the real world, one plus one equals three, would you take a leap of faith that maybe there are other answers out there? So the one plus one, and even one times one, would equal three. Yeah. We have to start to define the words that we mean by that and the lived experience of them. So could you give an example that is a little bit more concrete of that for the clinical psychology students that have just taken their first research one-on-one class that are
他们开始变得相当僵化，在他们的思维中，就像这是我被教导的。这就是受过训练与受过教育的区别，或者生活经验与我知道问题的答案之间的区别，而且，你知道，对于客户，有些客户就像，你知道，相当，你知道，就像一加一等于二，没有其他答案，伙计。在现实世界中，是的，我在这里加上这些限定词是为了提升它。嗯，但你知道，答案会相当惹恼那些被困住的人。我想对我们正在开启的对话保持敏感。
going to email me and say that I shouldn't have a license right after this episode airs. Just go ahead and speak directly to them because they're there. They're listening. OK. So you mean you think I have to give them the answer? No just get maybe make that concept a little bit more concrete. Well this is this is more just because I think it would be funny than you know. So the as far as the answer I mean as far as the dissociative kind
我觉得这就是我正在做这件事的原因，因为我们要谈论迷幻药，如果我们谈论解离，如果人们认为解离是心灵的缺失，那是身体的存在，吉姆。大脑的另一部分，我们通常没有意识地参与的网络。潜意识就是身体。当身体接管时，因为心灵关闭了，我们谈论的是默认模式网络。是的。我们谈论的是换挡进入另一种状态，一个经历过或没有经历过的人，
of spectrum is kind of what I was looking at. So when we look at the spectrum of it, we find pathology and we find, you know, a normative range. So if the norms are kind of labeling the pathology, then what would the pathology label the norm kind of a thing? And I think I think a lot of artists and a lot of people have done that enough that like we can kind of see kind of what their opinion of the normative is. And if we are gonna be normal as like, okay, so one plus one equals two, that's the reality that we live in. That's when things add up. And usually when people say things aren't adding up, they say that it's irrational or there's something wrong with that answer, right?
你知道，一个经历过但不知道那是什么，觉得有什么不对劲的人。那个会把一加一只能等于二贴上标签的部分，听到这个答案会觉得，噢。而且这个答案很简单。它是母亲、父亲、婴儿。这是关于你参与了什么过程，这些数字是否涉及过去、现在和未来？一加一等于三。有一个，你知道，我相信定性与定量之间的哲学基础。如果你能够听到你在，就像它是僵化的，你可能在你的左脑，而那一加一只能等于二。嗯，那是你被教导和训练的，但现实世界也是这样的。所以那些在现实世界中带着解离生活的人是高度适应的。这就是解离不是缺失的地方。所以当我们定义潜意识拥有意识，并且它是你的生活体验时，那么你的生活体验就开始比其他人使用的词汇更有价值。我也开始看解离和学习障碍，因为他们有，玛雅·萨拉洛维茨（Maia Szalavitz）有一本关于未破碎大脑的书，关于，以及她对成瘾的陈述，
They start to be pretty pretty like, you know, rigid in their like thinking like this is what I was taught. And this is the difference between, you know, trained versus educated and or lived experience versus, you know, I know the answer to the question and like, and not, you know, with clients, some clients are like, you know, pretty, you know, like one plus one equals two, there's no, there's no, there's no, there's no other answer, dude. Like in the real world, like, yes, I'm putting these qualifiers in there to kind of boost, boost it up. Um, but you know, the answer will rather annoy those who are stuck. And I want to be sensitive to like the conversation that we're opening.
是学习障碍，因为你不断地重复做同样的事情，期待不同的结果。这就像，不，这里有一种解离系统因过去无法自然解决的创伤而超载的缓解重演，或者通过手段，或者通过仅仅带着它生活并硬撑过去，那变得很沉重。所以当我审视这些系统时，我认为这在这次对话中会很有价值，
And I feel like this is the reason why I'm doing is because we're gonna talk about psychedelics and if we're gonna talk about Dissociation if people think that dissociation is the absence of mind it is the presence of body Jim Another part of the brain another part of the network that we normally are not consciously engaging with. And the unconscious is the body. And as the body takes over because the mind is off, we're talking about the default mode network. Yeah. We're talking about a shifting of a gear into another state that a person who has or has not experienced it,
当我们开始审视它的生物学时，身体在某种意义上是无辜的，因为它会相信你告诉它的东西，直到它有其他什么，嗯-嗯。它会给出，你知道，它会给出，那个，那个，那个，嗯-嗯，那个，那个，噢，检查出来，那个，别相信它。现在无论这是否与某些主题有关，但如果我们能够处于中性状态，我们可以接收积极和消极的东西，这也是一种冥想类型的事情。我们可以只是见证思想和感受，积极的和消极的，
you know, a person who has and doesn't know what it is and feel like there's something going wrong. The part that would label that one plus one only equals two would hear this answer and be like, Uh-oh. And it's pretty simple of an answer. And it's mother, father, baby. It's about what process are you involved, are these numbers involved in past, present and future? One plus one equals three. There's a, there's a, you know, and I'm sure the philosophical kind of underpinnings of, of, of qualitative versus quantitative. If you, if you are in, if you're able to hear that you're in, like it was rigid, you're probably in your left brain and that one plus one can only equal two. Well, that's what you were taught and trained, but like also the real world is this. So people who live in the real world with dissociation are highly
让它们存在一会儿。那种中性对于能够拥有是非常重要的。而解离作为一个过程不是中性的。它是现场的第一响应者。是的。它在麻痹你。所以大麻素系统可以进来并开始帮助你治愈。所以当我说
adaptable. And this is where dissociation is not the absence of. And so when we define the unconscious as having a consciousness and it is your lived experience, then your lived experience starts to be much more valuable than the words that other people use. And I also have started to look at like, um, dissociation and learning disorder because they have, you know, piped in, um, Maya Salalovitz has a book called the unbroken brain about, and her kind of presentation on, you know, addiction
人们对创伤上瘾，范德考克（Vander Kolk）是第一个在文献中相对这样说的人，1985年，他谈到了人们对身体阿片系统的依赖。身体中的阿片系统，纳曲酮，正如许多临床医生正在了解的那样，纳曲酮就像一个跨诊断特征，因为它被用于饮食失调、减肥手术、解离性障碍，
being in learning disorder, because you keep doing the same thing over and over again, expecting different results. It's just like, no, I'm there's a reenactment here of relief that I am reenacting that I need because the dissociative system is overloaded by either past trauma that hasn't been able to resolve naturally or through means or, you know, through, you know, just living with it and toughing it out and that gets heavy. So when I was looking at the systems, I think this will be valuable in this conversation
酒精渴望，显然是针对阿片类药物的手段。我的意思是，任何东西，我们对消费和购买之类的成瘾过程有清晰的理解，但当治愈过程的开始是阿片类药物，而其他人将其贴上问题的标签时，解离效应就开始把你带到一个时间无关紧要的土地上。
that when we start looking at the biology of it, the body is really innocent in the sense that it is going to believe what it is that you are telling it until it has some other like, uh-uh. And it's going to give like, uh-uh, you know, and it's going to give, and that, that, that, like, uh-uh, that, that, uh-oh, checked out, that, that, don't believe it. And now whether or not that's, you know, related to like kind of, you know, certain themes, but like, if, if we are able to be in a neutral state, we can receive the positives and negatives, and this is a meditative type of thing, too. We can just kind of witness the thoughts and the feelings and the positive and the negative
你在杏仁核中。患有复杂PTSD的人通常有那种，我会说硬币的另一面是，有些人对数字太僵化，有些人对数字太灵活，没有那种来回的混合体验。现在，关于我，在我的旅程中，你知道，我的生活经验是我发生了一次事故，你知道，我大约三岁时的一次简单的事故。这一直是我现实的一部分。我过着足够好的生活，有很多发展，我有皮肤问题和出生前之类的疼痛问题。但我记得的灵魂出窍体验
and just let them be for a little bit. That neutral is so important to be able to have. And dissociation as a process isn't neutral. It is the first responder on the scene. Yeah. It is numbing you. So the cannabinoid system can come and start helping you heal. So when I say
以及它与解离系统的联系，其中解离在阿片版本与解离进入迷幻版本之间，我们有松果体与阿片和内源性大麻素系统，对，我们谈论的是生物学，我不是称任何人是瘾君子，但如果他们的阿片类药物没有得到满足，他们会表现得像瘾君子。所以我们去看电视或戏剧，人们陷入这些新的循环中。
that people are addicted to trauma, which Vander Kolk was the first to relatively say that in the literature, 1985, he was talking about the dependence of people being the opioid system in the body. The opioid system in the body, the naltrexone, as a lot of clinicians are learning, is that naltrexone is like a transdiagnostic feature because it's being used for eating disorder, bariatric surgeries, it's being used for dissociative disorders,
我的意思是，我认为大多数人现在正在摆脱，并寻找他们自己的老师，而不是新的来源。他们想要一个对他们有意义的框架。当我开始审视解离以及人们如何可能对创伤或除药物或赌博之外的任何东西上瘾时，因为那是我们拥有的仅有的两个真正的合法东西。我不买账，我的学士学位是历史，我看着我们知道绝对权力导致绝对腐败有多久了。
alcohol cravings, obviously for the opioid means to it. I mean, anything, we have a clear understanding of the addictive processes with spending and buying and stuff like that, but like, when the start of the healing process is the opiate and somebody else labels that as the problem, well, the dissociative effect starts taking you into a land where time doesn't matter.
所以那不是成瘾吗？嗯，我的意思是，我写过一点关于你似乎正在触及的事情，即像解离、联觉、成瘾这样的事情，比我们假装的要正常得多。我们只是在它们达到这里之前不说它们是症状。当它们对掌权者造成问题时，它们就变得有问题了。他们开始给它贴标签。是的，而正在经历的人，我的意思是很多时候，你知道，我相信你有那种人们开始，你知道，
You're in the amygdala. People who have complex PTSD usually have that kind of, and I would say the other side of the coin is that some people are so rigid in their numbers and some people are so fluid in their numbers, there isn't that like, you know, hybrid kind of experience back and forth. Now, a little bit about me, in my journey, and you know, the my lived experience was I had an accident, you know, a pretty simple accident when I was about three. And this has always been my my reality. And I had a good enough life, a bunch of developmental, I have skin issues and like pain problems from pre-verb, you know, from my birth and stuff like that. But the, the out of body experience that I remember
他们给它贴上标签，好像发生了其他他们无法解释的事情，然后他们去看医生，无论他们是否能翻译它？我的意思是，我真的想帮助医学模型，你知道，得到，如果我，我希望医学模型能够得到潜意识知情同意。嗯，这就是解离的问题，你熟悉大卫·格兰德（David Grand）做的脑点（Brainspotting）或史蒂文·瓦斯奎兹（Steven Vasquez）博士做的情感转化疗法（ETT）吗？更熟悉大卫·格兰德。我是脑点认证顾问。好的。
and its connection to the dissociative system of which dissociation in the opiate version versus dissociation into like the psychedelic version where we have the pineal gland versus the opioid and cannabinoid system, Right, we're talking about like biological, I'm not calling anybody an addict, but like they would behave like an addict if like their drug opiates weren't like getting their hit. So like we go to like the TV or the drama and like people get caught in these new cycles.
所以我同时使用ETT和脑点，脑点，如果没人熟悉，我不，如果你不熟悉，你可能没听过这个节目的很多集，但它是一种眼位疗法，我发现它比EMDR对更多人更有效，而且也更受控，在处理方式上，然后情感转化疗法使用几种设备，但它基本上是光、颜色、闪烁频率，非常具体地使用颜色，以及光线对瞳孔的方向。你可以处理得慢一点，
I mean, I think most people are now, are kind of getting away from, and seeking their own kind of like teacher rather than like new source. They want a framing of something that makes sense to them. And when I start looking at how dissociation and how people could be addicted to trauma or addicted to anything other than a drug or gambling, because those are the only two real legal ones we have. And I don't, I'm not buying that. And I'm, I, my bachelorors is in history And I look at like how long have we known the absolute power corrupts absolutely
但比脑点更具手术性。我两者结合使用，特别是针对解离。但我试图告诉人们的一件事是，我对经典认知行为治疗计划的问题之一是，我告诉人们，当你的解离下降时，你的目标将会改变。就像你告诉我你对你的现实感到满意，你的伴侣对你施虐或情感虐待，或者你的环境不安全，
So is that not addiction? Well, I mean one of the things that I've written about a little bit that it seems like you're hitting on is that things like dissociation things like synesthesia things like addiction are Way more normal than we pretend They are we just don't say that they're a symptom until they're all the way up here They become problematic when they're problematic for those in charge. They start to label it. Yeah, and The person who is experiencing I mean a lot of times that you know I'm sure you have like those experiences where people start to you know
但你对此很酷，而且你一直在康复，但你有酒精问题之类的。当我降低解离时，你将开始以一种方式感受到你的情感体验，这些事情将成为一个更现实的问题，而且它们就像试图向鱼解释水外是什么一样，就像它们还无法构想那样。我试图说，我想让你感受到这一点，我想让你说我已经和多个人做过这件事，就像，相信我的话。一旦你的解离能力下降，你将开始致力于调节你将开始感受到的情绪量。
They label that like something else is happening to them that they can't explain and Then they go to a medical and like whether or not they can you know translate it? I mean, I would really like to help the medical model, you know get What if I I would want the medical model to be able to get unconscious informed consent Well, that's the problem with dissociation is like you familiar with brain- brain spotting that David Grand does or emotional transformation therapy that Dr. Steven Vasquez does? More familiar with David Grand. I'm an approved consultant in brain spotting. Okay.
你在脑点中看到这一点吗？或者这有意义吗？哦，这有意义。我，一点背景，我认为这很有帮助，因为我们可以比较和对比，不一定是针对彼此，你知道，我们，而是我们所做的不同事情。所以我还做渐进计数，这是由瑞奇·格林沃尔德（Ricky Greenwald）博士开发的，他最初是我的EMDR培训师，然后是深层大脑重定向（Deep Brain Reorienting），谁验证或确认了，你知道，脑点，弗兰克·科里根（Frank Corrigan）和迷幻药。所以我玩过的问题是，当你
So one of the things that I use ETT and brain spotting together, brain spotting, if no one's familiar, which I don't, you probably haven't listened to many of this episodes of the show if you're not familiar but it's a I position therapy that I find to be a lot more effective for more people than EMDR is and then also and also a lot more controlled and how you process and then emotional transformation therapy uses the Several devices but it's basically light color flicker rates very specific use of color, and then direction of light against the pupil. And you can process a little slower,
减少某人的解离时，你基本上是在说你把他们放进了他们的身体里。因为他们的身体在排斥他们，因为有痛苦。绝对。在某种程度上，对吧？但你不能，当你提到潜意识同意时，这就是我开始谈论它的原因，因为你不能为一个你没有感觉到的痛苦制定治疗计划。即使我知道它在那里，你知道？对。这就是，如果阿片系统作为主要的解离特征在起作用。而且如果你有像生病的人，你知道，无论是毒瘾发作还是，这是一个很好的例子，有人，他们处于，无论是毒瘾发作还是，这是一个很好的例子，有人，他们处于，得到那个，在他们那种阿片类药物不舒服、暴躁的阶段。但如果人们处于他们那种解离的、想象的世界中，它对我来说下降到，你知道，Theta Alpha和，你知道，
but a little bit more surgically than brain spotting. And I use both of them together with dissociation, especially. But one of the things that I try and tell people for, one of my issues with like the classic cognitive behavioral treatment plan is like, I'm telling people when your dissociation comes down your goals are about to change. Like you're telling me that you're fine with your reality, that your partner is abusive to you or emotionally abusive to you or that your environment isn't safe
Theta Beta和Alpha比例，因为我也做神经反馈。并把人们放在他们的——你也能在那里做QEEG脑图吗？是的，是的，是的。这对于能够看到当我做治疗时，在神经调节开始之前大脑发生了什么变化非常重要。那真的很疯狂。
but you're cool with that and that you've been in recovery but you had a problem with alcohol whatever. When I bring dissociation down you're going to start to feel your emotional experience in a way where those things will become a much more present problem and They it's like trying to explain to a fish what's outside of water like they're like they can't conceive of that yet And I'm trying to say I want you to feel this I want you to kind of say that I've done this with multiple people and like Just take my word for it. Once your ability to dissociate comes down You're going to be working on regulating the amount of motion that you're going to start to feel.
Theta非常重要。所以，解离效应，你知道，如果身体在踢出心灵，这是一个心灵占百分之几，身体占百分之几的问题。因为身体可能在关闭系统，这就是为什么身体作为潜意识对我来说如此重要，因为它确实帮助我们能够定义是谁在给予什么许可，对吧？是谁，谁有意见，谁有生活经验？我和范德考克以及他的妻子露西亚·斯凯（Lucia Skye）做了一个小组讨论，我们谈论身体作为一个微分系统，意味着它就像0和1，如果你知道如何与它对话，它就能给你答案。0和1，如果你知道如何与它对话，它就能给你答案。
Do you see that in brain spawning or does that make sense? Oh, it makes sense. I so a little kind of background, I think it's helpful because we can compare and contrast not necessarily against each other's, you know, us but like our different things that we do. So I also do progressive counting, which is was developed by Dr. Ricky Greenwald who was my EMDR trainer originally and then deep brain reorienting with who validated or kind of confirmed you know brain spotting Frank Corrigan and psychedelics. So the question that I have played with is that when you are
潜意识知情同意是让你的身体对某事表示同意，但人们的神经连接可能会交叉。所以我的濒死体验确实交叉了我的神经，因为我以为麻木就是平静，我的标签系统会与其他人完全相反。我必须以我自己的方式学习这一点。我还有我的皮肤状况，我基本上会抓挠直到流血，那实际上感觉很好。所以，我的神经再次交叉了，从这个意义上说。所以我在交叉我们的神经，治愈和所有那个过程。你知道什么系统
decreasing somebody's dissociation, you're basically saying that you are putting them into their body. Because their body is rejecting them because there is pain. Absolutely. On some level, right? But you can't, when you said unconscious consent, that's why I started talking about that because you can't make a treatment plan
正在激活，我认为你知道我们必须对什么保持谨慎，比如，是的，有时人们有想象的东西。我最喜欢思考的最大事情是这种重演，比如，为什么历史会重演，以及我们如何与它对话？我们如何让它停止？我们需要做什么，无论是个人还是社会，你知道，在那个我们，或者个人还是社会，你知道，嗯，那个个人，当我们能与潜意识对话时，嗯，我认为这有点像，如果潜意识
for a pain that you are not feeling. Even if I know that it's there, you know? Right. That's the, if the opioid system is at play as the primary dissociative feature. And if you have somebody who's like sick, like, you know, whether it's dope sick or like, that's a good example of somebody who's kind of, they're in their, whether it's dope sick or like, that's a good example of somebody who's kind of, get that right up there in there kind of like opiate kind of like uncomfortable grumpy stage. But if people are in there like kind of dissociated, like imaginative world and it kind of comes down to me for like, you know, theta alpha and you know,
针对你并未感受到的痛苦。即使我知道它在那里，你懂吗？对。如果阿片系统作为主要的解离特征在起作用，就是这样。如果有人生病了，比如，你知道，无论是毒瘾发作还是其他情况，那是一个很好的例子，说明某人处于那种，无论是毒瘾发作还是其他情况，那是一个很好的例子，说明某人处于那种，把那个状态准确地定位在那种阿片类药物引起的不适和暴躁阶段。但如果人们处于那种解离的、想象的世界中，对我来说，这归结为，你知道，θ波、α波，你知道，
theta beta and and alpha ratios, because I also do neurofeedback. And putting people in their- Can you do some QDG brain mapping there too? Yeah, yeah, yeah. That was huge to be able to see when I did therapy what changed in the brain before neuromodulation started. That was really wild.
θ波、β波和α波的比率，因为我也做神经反馈。让人们处于他们的——你也能在那里做QEEG脑图吗？是的，是的，是的。能够看到我在做治疗时大脑发生了什么变化，在神经调节开始之前，这非常重要。那真的很疯狂。
Theta is incredibly important. So like the dissociative effect, you know, if the body is kicking out the mind, it's a matter of what percentage is the mind and what percentage is the body. Because the body may be turning off the systems and that's why the body being the unconscious is so important to me, because it does help us be able to define who is giving what permission, right? And who is like, who has an opinion, who has a lived experience? And I did a panel with Bander Kolk and his, his wife, Lucia Skye, and we were talking about like the body being a differential system, meaning that it's like ones and zeros, and like it can give you answers if you know how to talk to it. ones and zeros and like it can give you answers if you know how to talk to it.
θ波极其重要。所以，比如解离效应，你知道，如果身体排斥心灵，问题在于心灵占多少比例，身体占多少比例。因为身体可能会关闭系统，这就是为什么身体作为潜意识对我来说如此重要，因为它确实帮助我们能够定义是谁给予了许可，对吧？谁有意见，谁有生活经验？我和范德考克以及他的妻子露西亚·斯凯参加了一个小组讨论，我们谈论的是身体作为一个微分系统，意味着它就像一和零，如果你知道如何与它对话，它就能给你答案。一和零，如果你知道如何与它对话，它就能给你答案。
Unconscious informed consent is having your body be agreeable to something, but people's wirings can be crossed. So my near death experience really crossed my wires because I thought that numb was calm and I, my labeling system would have been all backwards comparative to like everybody else's. And I had to learn that kind of in my own way. I also had my skin condition I basically will itch until I bleed and that actually felt good. So like then there might my wires get crossed again in that sense. So I'm crossing our wires healing and all that process. You know what system
潜意识知情同意是指让你的身体对某事表示赞同，但人们的神经回路可能会错乱。所以我的濒死体验确实让我的神经回路错乱了，因为我以为麻木就是平静，我的标记系统与其他人相比完全是颠倒的。我必须以自己的方式学习这一点。我还有皮肤状况，我基本上会抓挠到流血，而那实际上感觉很好。所以在那方面我的神经回路又错乱了。所以我正在理顺我们的神经回路、疗愈以及所有这些过程。你知道什么系统
is activating and I think you know some of what we have to be kind of cautious of, like, yes, sometimes people have imaginative stuff. And the biggest thing that I like, I love to kind of think about is this reenactment, like, why does history repeat and like, how can we talk to it? How can we get it to stop? What is it that we need to do, whether that's individual or personally or like society, you know, in that when we or personally or like society, you know, um, and that individual, when we can talk to the unconscious, uh, I think it's kind of like on, if the unconscious
正在激活，我认为你知道我们必须谨慎对待的一些事情，比如，是的，有时人们会有想象中的东西。我最喜欢思考的一件事是这种重演，比如，为什么历史会重演，我们该如何与它对话？我们怎样才能让它停止？我们需要做什么，无论是个人还是社会，你知道，当我们或者个人还是社会，你知道，嗯，那个个体，当我们能够与潜意识对话时，呃，我认为这有点像，如果潜意识
is accept accessible and communicative, then people are going to get a lot out of their work. And I see that with my more dissociative clients, they have much more access to be honest with themselves and much more capacity than those who have it shut off. And the things that- It's fascinating because what they do is a lot of times like they tend to have like lower self-esteem or second guess themselves, or they've plugged into life. And a lot of them are very successful and smart, but they don't really trust, you know,
如果能够接受、易于沟通，那么人们就能从他们的工作中获得很多收获。我在那些解离程度较高的客户身上看到了这一点，他们比那些封闭自己的人更能够诚实地面对自己，也拥有更大的潜能。有趣的是，他们往往自尊心较低，或者容易自我怀疑，又或者与生活脱节。他们中许多人非常聪明且成功，但他们并不真正信任，你知道，
their own sense of self in the community or in the environment. But when it comes down to like the core parts of identity that you want to reconnect most people to, it's like they'll go to the map for those and they never forgot those things because they are spending so much time in the brainstem, they're spending so much time in Theta wave that those more emotional truths that you have to teach other patients that are less dissociative to recognize, they are not ever good.
他们在社区或环境中的自我感。但当涉及到你希望大多数人重新建立联系的核心身份部分时，他们会为了这些部分全力以赴，而且他们从未忘记过这些东西，因为他们花太多时间在脑干中，花太多时间在Theta波状态下，以至于那些你必须教导其他解离程度较低的患者去识别的情感真相，他们其实一直都很清楚。
They don't have the luxury of pretending those things aren't real. But I don't know, that's what I don't know. Who is dissociated? Cause I had to live, I was trapped in my body, in my brain stem. Like at three, there was a part of me that was stuck there in a sense.
他们没有那种假装这些事情不是真实的奢侈。但我不知道，这就是我不知道的地方。谁是解离的？因为我必须活着，我被困在我的身体里，在我的脑干里。就像在三岁时，我的一部分在某种意义上被困在那里了。
And there was a part that went on. And so like, I can tap into that three-year-old and have those biological processes understood. I can have a kind of like communicative yes or no type of conversation. Like, I mean, like how much of our language is nonverbal? Yeah. You know, so like really teaching people,
而另一部分继续前行。所以我可以触及那个三岁的自己，并理解那些生物学过程。我可以进行一种类似沟通式的“是”或“否”的对话。我的意思是，我们的语言中有多少是非语言的？是的。所以，真正教导人们，
you know, what that is, and you know, not necessarily kind of going down the parts rabbit hole, but like those facets of self. So my other math equation is like the youngest part of you is the oldest one. And that's the wisdom that therapy has been seeking that people could like find within themselves is that like you've been through this before.
你知道，那是什么，而且，你知道，不一定要钻进“部分”的兔子洞，而是那些自我的侧面。所以我的另一个数学公式是：你最年轻的部分就是最古老的部分。这就是治疗一直在寻求的智慧，人们可以在自己内心找到这种智慧，那就是你以前经历过这些。
Yeah. You've been here before. Well, how many people do, I read all of these biographies of people that I think are in touch with that. A lot of them are dead and very old, some of them are still around. Then you also talk to therapists a lot about, or I talked to therapists a lot about reconnecting people to something.
是的。你以前来过这里。好吧，有多少人，我读过所有我认为与此有共鸣的人的传记。他们中许多人已经去世，年纪很大，有些人还健在。然后你也经常和治疗师谈论，或者我经常和治疗师谈论关于让人们与某样东西重新建立联系。
Everybody seems to describe the breakthrough that is healing and midlife or the thing that lets them kind of put things back together as this remembering of something that was forgotten in so many different languages. You know, but that's what all of them are saying is that I was born knowing this or I knew this before I was born and I forgot that and now I'm reconnected to it. But you know, you can't. We hear the same thing as psychedelics. That makes the empiricists so mad. The objective researchers so mad because they're like, what is this woo woo thing? How can I randomize control trial that?
每个人似乎都将那种治愈性的突破，或者那种让他们在人生中期能够把事情重新拼凑起来的东西，描述为对某种被遗忘事物的回忆，尽管用的是不同的语言。你知道，但他们所有人都在说的是，我生来就知道这一点，或者我在出生前就知道这一点，但我忘记了，现在我重新与它建立了联系。但你知道，你不能。我们在迷幻药方面也听到了同样的事情。这让经验主义者非常生气。客观研究人员非常生气，因为他们会说，这是什么伪科学的东西？我怎么能对它进行随机对照试验呢？
It's like you can in that everyone tends to say this when they get better and you can listen to that language, but you can't necessarily put it in a randomized control style trial study that is completely quantifiable you know right and that's the limitations of it i don't mind that that exists but i don't feel that like because you don't have the answers that doesn't mean that mine is you know not valid i would say that it exists whether or not you're mine you know well it's a mind Well, it's a matter of who has that preference I want to know who has that preference within your psyche and if we start talking about and this is where you know, like some of the bigger
就像你可以，因为每个人在好转时往往都会这么说，你可以倾听那种语言，但你不一定能把它放进一个完全可量化的随机对照试验研究中，你知道，对吧，这就是它的局限性。我不介意这种局限性存在，但我不觉得因为你没有答案，就意味着我的答案是无效的。我会说，无论你是否理解，它都存在。你知道，好吧，这是一个关于谁有这种偏好的问题。我想知道在你的心理中是谁有这种偏好，如果我们开始谈论，这就是你知道的，一些更大的
ramifications, I think even legally though, but like I mean Psychology if it takes psychology whatever eight to twelve times to diagnose dissociative dissociative disorders and like whatever, eight to twelve times to diagnose dissociative disorders. It doesn't take that long. And we have to kind of question where we rank our educational system. I think we have to question who is in charge to be able to, you know, feed us lines, like follow the science, but then don't allow us to. But the science is pretty clear with psychedelics. I don't know why I have to ask permission. But Adam, I did my PhD on just a mere 65 questions that you can ask a patient to find out
后果，我认为甚至在法律上也是如此，但我的意思是，如果心理学需要八到十二次才能诊断出解离性障碍，不管怎样，八到十二次才能诊断出解离性障碍。其实不需要那么久。我们必须质疑我们将教育系统排在什么位置。我认为我们必须质疑是谁在负责，能够向我们灌输“遵循科学”之类的说辞，但随后又不允许我们这样做。但科学在迷幻药方面是非常明确的。我不知道为什么我必须请求许可。但是亚当，我的博士论文仅仅是关于你可以问患者的65个问题，以找出
if they empirically have anxiety or not. So I just distrust if you could just talk to me for a minute and tell that I'm incredibly anxious. I don't think that that, I don't think that that. I could understand why people wouldn't trust that. And that's why the lived experience. I'm making a joke. I don't have a PhD. And I would never give you 65 questions. I'm, I'm making fun of a perspective in the industry that emails me for some reason.
他们是否在经验上患有焦虑症。所以我只是不信任，如果你能和我谈一分钟，就能看出我非常焦虑。我不认为，我不认为。我能理解为什么人们不信任这一点。这就是为什么生活经验很重要。我在开玩笑。我没有博士学位。我永远不会给你65个问题。我是在嘲笑行业内出于某种原因给我发邮件的某种观点。
I have other podcasts you can listen to. If you, if you told me that there was 211 questions, I would have been like, yeah, I know exactly what you're talking about. told me that there was 211 questions, I would have been like, yeah, I know exactly what you're talking about. Yeah. Well, I mean, we want to have these empirical metrics so that we can study things. We need them. We need them because the law needs them.
我有其他播客你可以听。如果你告诉我那是211个问题，我会说，是的，我完全知道你在说什么。告诉我那是211个问题，我会说，是的，我完全知道你在说什么。是的。好吧，我的意思是，我们想要这些经验指标，以便我们可以研究事物。我们需要它们。我们需要它们，因为法律需要它们。
Yeah. The law wants them. The law wants us to tell people, hey, here, sign this thing first before we talk. I mean, if you need eight to 12 sessions to tell if somebody has dissociation, I think there's a serious problem. I mean, I'll admit there's times where I'm like, maybe this person slightly on the autism spectrum and there's dissociation or maybe I'm just seeing this, you know, I see the kind of deep awareness of the body while also like a disconnection from it.
是的。法律需要它们。法律希望我们告诉人们，嘿，在这里，在我们交谈之前先签这份文件。我的意思是，如果你需要8到12次会谈才能判断某人是否有解离，我认为这有一个严重的问题。我的意思是，我会承认有时我会想，也许这个人稍微有点自闭症谱系障碍，并且伴有解离，或者也许我只是看到了这一点，你知道，我看到了那种对身体的深度觉知，同时也看到了与它的脱节。
Like I see that it's kind of in charge, but somebody doesn't know that. Or I see like an absence and And it takes a while to figure out exactly what the flavor of that is or what's going on sometimes But to miss it entirely, I think well, it's not just a matter of eight sessions I what that statistic is is it takes eight different like it took me five times to get an accurate diagnosis That means that could have been with that therapist for years, not just eight sessions, they could have been with somebody and I have plenty of clients in their history. They were with somebody and that this I was the first one. I mean, finding out that somebody's dissociative and now granted that the other clinicians may
就像我看到它在某种程度上是主导的，但某人并不知道这一点。或者我看到一种缺失，有时需要一段时间才能弄清楚那到底是什么味道，或者发生了什么。但完全忽略它，我认为，好吧，这不仅仅是八次会谈的问题。那个统计数据是，它需要八个不同的……比如我花了五次才得到准确的诊断。这意味着他们可能和那个治疗师在一起好几年了，不仅仅是八次会谈，他们可能和某人在一起，而且我有许多客户在他们的历史中。他们和某人在一起，而我是第一个发现的。我的意思是，发现某人是解离的，现在当然，其他临床医生可能
have known this and I don't have their reports and I don't have like empirical evidence. I mean, this is where like, give me the facts, give me the facts. And that's where again, I go back to this James Webb telescope of like, the facts are proving that like, this is the same phenomena, no matter the chicken or the egg, you're gonna have to start to believe that like evolution would have had an in between stage. Now, now I mean, this is just kind of the philosophical of it too, is I guess, uh, uh, Rudolph Steiner, um, had some credit, you know, had credibility in the philosophical world for like saying that there is a transition, there's a fourth or there's a fifth form where there is a transitional state. And I think, you know, when we start to look at dissociation as a transitional state, like if somebody's dissociated, I say welcome.
已经知道了这一点，但我没有他们的报告，我也没有经验证据。我的意思是，这就是“给我事实，给我事实”的地方。这就是我再次回到詹姆斯·韦伯望远镜的地方，事实证明，无论先有鸡还是先有蛋，这都是同样的现象，你必须开始相信进化会有一个中间阶段。现在，我的意思是，这在哲学上也只是某种……我想，鲁道夫·斯坦纳在哲学界有一定的信誉，因为他说存在一个过渡，存在第四或第五种形式，即存在一个过渡状态。我认为，你知道，当我们开始将解离视为一种过渡状态时，比如如果某人解离了，我会说欢迎。
Yeah. Because if somebody is checking out, that means somebody is checking in. You can't have one without the other And you can talk to the absent-minded, you know, and you know It may look like talking to a catatonic person on you know, not suggesting that we do this But I'm just saying when somebody kind of goes blank They're kind of look like they're brain-spotting and I kind of just say is there somebody else here and like that that part gets permission at that if if if
是的。因为如果某人正在“退出”，那就意味着某人正在“进入”。你不可能拥有其中一个而没有另一个。你可以和心不在焉的人交谈，你知道，这看起来可能像是在和一个紧张症患者交谈，你知道，并不是建议我们这样做，但我只是说，当某人变得空白时，他们看起来有点像在进行“脑点定位”（Brainspotting），我只是说，还有别人在这里吗？如果……如果……
Whether they be CBT dominant in their belief structure or cognitive that one plus one can only equal two, then like, yes, I do have a lot of concerns for people who are missing that dissociation as a transdiagnostic. And the bigger picture to me is that like addiction as transdiagnostic Should have been obvious for a long time Well, but a lot of times like when I talked to Andrews 20 is an urban planner
无论他们的信仰结构中是CBT（认知行为疗法）占主导地位，还是认知上认为1+1只能等于2，那么，是的，对于那些忽略了解离作为一种跨诊断因素的人，我确实有很多担忧。对我来说，更大的图景是，成瘾作为一种跨诊断因素，应该早就显而易见了。好吧，但很多时候，当我与安德鲁斯谈话时，他是位城市规划师，
he was like, you know, the biggest problem and the biggest problem in like that community is when somebody doesn't want it or he's talking about architecture and You know contractors who he's like when somebody doesn't want to, or he's talking about architecture and, you know, contractors, he's like, when somebody doesn't want to know something about a design, they start to pretend that it needs more research. And you just have to say, I'm not researching something that's self-evident. I can sit here and I can watch this happening. And so I'll have things happen where somebody will say, well, you know, what do I do? What about ketamine for this? You know, the provider. And I'm like, well, I like ketamine for some things, but I don't really like it for dissociative disorders because it's a dissociative drug. And they're like, well, what's the research on that? Who said that? And I'm like, I don't think there is any, I don't really need.
他说，你知道，那个社区最大的问题是当某人不想……或者他在谈论建筑，你知道，承包商，他说，当某人不想知道关于设计的某些事情时，他们就开始假装需要更多的研究。你只需要说，我不会去研究那些显而易见的事情。我可以坐在这里，看着它发生。所以我会遇到这样的事情，有人会说，好吧，你知道，我该怎么办？氯胺酮对这个有用吗？你知道，提供者。我说，好吧，我喜欢氯胺酮用于某些事情，但我不太喜欢它用于解离性障碍，因为它是一种解离性药物。他们会说，那关于它的研究是什么？谁说的？我说，我不认为有任何研究，我真的不需要。
It's categorically, I mean, So the drug you're using to try and treat a dissociative disorder, you're going to put that person further into dissociation. Like if somebody has got an acute flashbulb re-experiencing of trauma and they're not scoring high for dissociation, maybe if somebody's got an acute flashbulb re-experiencing of trauma and they're not scoring high for dissociation maybe if somebody's got a hopeless helpless depression with no dissociative element. Well I mean I mean as far as you know like I'm not one to kind of go on scales as to like whether or not like how dissociated somebody is because it's hard to measure it's a matter of who is dissociated, who is not there.
这是绝对的，我的意思是，所以你用来试图治疗解离性障碍的药物，会把那个人进一步推向解离。就像如果某人有创伤的急性闪回重现，而他们的解离评分不高，也许如果某人有急性闪回重现，而他们的解离评分不高，也许如果某人有绝望、无助的抑郁，而没有解离成分。好吧，我的意思是，就你知道的而言，我不是那种会根据某人解离程度来使用量表的人，因为这很难衡量，这是一个关于谁解离了，谁不在那里了的问题。
So in my model, what I look at is like really creating, you know, a meeting area. I created a meeting area screening and assessment that I have like a, you know, a script that like a guideline that people can use. Yeah, so in like, you know, things like EMDR, so I'm also an EMDR trainer. And so when, when we ask a part of self, this is why I just be cautioned, cautious about like, you know, you know, this part is saying like, you know, like, I'm psychotic. And, or I'm, everything's fine. And I'm not scoring high in dissociation. I really feel like I'm here. I don't, going off of like, neurofeedback, I don't know how here you think you are. Yeah. Because you're thinking about it.
所以在我的模型中，我所看重的是真正创造一个“会面区域”。我创建了一个会面区域筛选和评估，我有一个脚本，一个人们可以使用的指南。是的，所以像EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）中，我也是一名EMDR培训师。所以当我们问自我的一个部分时，这就是为什么我只是保持谨慎，关于，你知道，这个部分说，你知道，我精神病了，或者我，一切都很好。而且我的解离评分不高。我真的觉得我在这里。我不知道，根据神经反馈，我不知道你认为你有多“在这里”。是的。因为你在思考它。
If somebody tells me, yeah, I think I'm here. It's just like, let me know when you know. Yeah. Well, what about how do you deal with kind of parts of self or parts of the network that are maybe not completely verbal or maybe are more relational, usually very young because I mean those tend to not have the same access to language a lot of the time. I mean how do I access them or how do I communicate with them? Just what do you feel like their role is clinically you know when it's not a part that can say I'm
如果有人告诉我，是的，我想我在这里。这就像，当你真的知道时再告诉我。是的。好吧，你如何处理那些可能不是完全言语化，或者可能更具关系性的自我部分或网络部分？通常非常年轻，因为我的意思是，它们往往在很多时候没有同样的语言获取能力。我的意思是，我如何获取它们，或者我如何与它们沟通？你觉得它们在临床上的角色是什么，你知道，当它不是一个能说“我”的部分时，
not quite here but you kind of feel the presence of somebody who has I look at posture a ton if somebody is like You know has more of a when I see very strong posture changes and tone changes Sometimes those parts just need to be kind of like Encouraged and made room for but they're not they don't really have a lot to say in language or they don't have access to language Right, and I mean or they don't have access to language. Right. And I mean, developmentally, there are reasons for that. And that's where we have to be able to switch
不是完全在这里，但你确实感觉到某人的存在。我非常关注姿势，如果某人有……你知道，有更多的……当我看到非常强烈的姿势变化和语调变化时，有时这些部分只需要被鼓励并为它们留出空间，但它们并没有太多语言上的表达，或者它们没有语言获取能力。对，我的意思是，或者它们没有语言获取能力。对。我的意思是，从发育角度来看，这是有原因的。这就是我们必须能够切换
into age-appropriate type of things to help them move through things and or get access to memories. So how do I do that? I kind of orient people towards, to me, the reality that I see. And I think it may be more of a spiritual bent or to me, the reality that I see, and I think it's maybe more of a spiritual bent or like somebody could label it as that. But I think it's actually psychologically, you know, sound and that I have to assume that you are if you walk in the door, you're bringing everybody with you. Whether you are aware of it or not. And
到适合年龄的事情，以帮助它们度过难关和/或获取记忆。所以我怎么做呢？我引导人们，对我来说，引导向我所看到的现实。我认为这可能更倾向于精神层面，或者对我来说，我看到的现实，我认为这可能更倾向于精神层面，或者有人可以将其标记为那样。但我认为它实际上在心理上是合理的，我必须假设如果你走进门，你就把每个人都带来了。无论你是否意识到。而且
that's kind of my point is like when we ask somebody today, zero to 10, how bad is that memory now? And they give me like a five and I say, okay, can you ask the person the age that it happened to? And they could tell me at 10. Then I know that they're not on the same page to be able to answer the question. And if you have a filter,
这就是我的观点，就像我们今天问某人，0到10分，那个记忆现在有多糟糕？他们给了我一个5分，我说，好吧，你能问问发生这件事时那个年龄的自己吗？他们可以告诉我10分。那么我就知道他们不在同一个页面上，无法回答这个问题。如果你有一个过滤器，
and this is where the learning disorder type of stuff is getting interesting because like auditory processing, either it is like a facet of an ear part that can only hear certain like pitches or hear certain language and it has to go through and it can't go through or if you hear it on this side and you hear things differently than you would on this side. it's all about how the brain receives the messages in those nonverbal type of cues and stuff like that. So like, yes, a lot of posture, a lot of bodily stuff. I don't really talk, I mean, as far as brain spotting, that's where I would go to a lot of my preverbal stuff. To your point earlier about EMDR brain spotting, and I would use EMDR later on for some more of the cognitions, the behavioral cognitions, but a lot of my preverbal stuff is very brain-spotting based to help the body find its regulation points
这就是学习障碍之类的事情变得有趣的地方，因为比如听觉处理，要么它是一个耳朵部分的侧面，只能听到某些音调或听到某些语言，它必须通过，但它无法通过；或者如果你在这边听到它，你听到的东西和你在那边听到的不同。这完全取决于大脑如何接收那些非语言线索等信息。所以，是的，很多姿势，很多身体上的东西。我真的不谈，我的意思是，就脑点定位而言，那是我会去处理很多前语言阶段东西的地方。回到你之前关于EMDR和脑点定位的观点，我会稍后使用EMDR来处理一些认知，行为认知，但我很多前语言阶段的东西是非常基于脑点定位的，以帮助身体找到它的调节点。
But also like test the system to see how it's going to respond to what I would call like adaptive dissociation or mindful dissociation Yeah And that is that's not an ox. It's only an oxymoron if you believe that nothing is nothing. Like that there's, I mean, the absence. I mean, the only thing we, I mean, the black holes are really like the absence that we don't know, but like I'm more than sure that they're connected
但也测试系统，看看它将如何响应我所说的“适应性解离”或“正念解离”。是的，那不是矛盾修辞。只有当你认为“无”就是“无”时，它才是矛盾修辞。就像，我的意思是，缺失。我的意思是，我们唯一能……我的意思是，黑洞确实就像我们不知道的缺失，但我非常确定它们与某处的某物相连。
to something somewhere. If something's eating something, it's going out some other door. So I don't, it just has to, you know, if it's an organism. So, so the other part too, is that like the, what I said to you earlier is that like the youngest parts are the oldest, meaning they held the wisdom. So like I'm 46, so my six year old self is 40 years old. If that math doesn't make sense to you, because it's emotional math, it's inversed math in
如果某物正在吞噬某物，它会从另一扇门出去。所以我不知道，它只需要，你知道，如果它是一个有机体。所以，另一个部分也是，就像我之前对你说的，最年轻的部分是最古老的，意味着它们持有智慧。所以，我46岁，所以我六岁的自己已经40岁了。如果那个数学对你来说没有意义，因为它是情感数学，它是反向数学，在
the sense that your six yearyear-old has been in the car for the last 40 years. Yeah. So when I start talking to the six-year-old as if they are, you know, equals and, and, or like, you know, I want to learn from you, I understand you've been here longer. If they're behaving like they are six or like have those six-year-old needs and stuff like that, then we want to structure the system is somewhat like where's the today you where's the future you how can we kind of create that and so when we're talking temporal space and time, we have to help people be able to create past, present and future them because a lot of themselves
某种意义上，你的六岁自己已经在车里坐了40年了。是的。所以当我开始和那个六岁的自己交谈，就好像他们是，你知道，平等的，或者像，你知道，我想向你学习，我理解你在这里待的时间更长。如果他们的行为就像他们是六岁，或者有那些六岁的需求之类的，那么我们想要构建这个系统，有点像“今天的你在哪里”，“未来的你在哪里”，我们如何创造那个？所以当我们谈论时间空间和时间时，我们必须帮助人们能够创造过去、现在和未来的自己，因为他们自己的很多部分
don't know what's going on and who's what and where is black again, it's really a circle. Yeah. It's really round. So what you're saying has so much resonance for ETT. When you ever get the emotional transformation therapy and look at what those colors do. It's it's wild because the far red end where you lose visibility of the red, it's almost like going into the body without you. So it's like experiencing the body without self whereas violet,
不知道发生了什么，谁是什么，哪里又是黑的，再次，它真的是一个圆。是的。它真的是圆的。所以你所说的对ETT（情感转化疗法）有很大的共鸣。当你接触到情感转化疗法并观察那些颜色所做的事情时。这太疯狂了，因为在远红端，你失去了对红色的可见性，这几乎就像在没有你的情况下进入身体。所以这就像在没有自我的情况下体验身体，而紫色，
the when you start to get violet loses visibility, you're going into higher order thinking without you So you get very secular or existential or spiritual higher concepts of like thought without yourself Where's the other one and and if someone's on an fMRI or a QEG and they look at? Far-red you get the same networks that activate with phantom limb syndrome with body dysmorphia with Dissociation due to sexual assault or some kind of invasive surgery and that stuff does have it more of a neurological basis than you know even Watts is aware of oh yeah yeah no doubt the color thing I saw something recently about that too I forget what it was called though but um yeah no that's i mean that's that's fascinating because like you know the
当你开始得到紫色失去可见性时，你正在进入没有你的高阶思维。所以你变得非常世俗、存在主义或精神层面的高阶概念，比如没有自我的思想。另一个在哪里？如果有人在fMRI（功能性磁共振成像）或QEG（定量脑电图）上，他们看远红光，你会得到与幻肢综合征、身体畸形恐惧症、由于性侵犯或某种侵入性手术导致的解离相同的激活网络，这些东西确实比你知道的瓦茨（Watts）意识到的更有神经学基础。哦，是的，毫无疑问，颜色这件事，我最近也看到了关于它的东西，但我忘了它叫什么了，但是……是的，不，那……我的意思是，那太迷人了，因为你知道，
you know how how you know how we're going to kind of do this is like you know and i i don't know we just have to be able to not question that there is a science psychology has a science here like qualitative is not nothing and we know more than what we're doing and more than what the medical and I would say the law kind of agrees is possible. Like we I see healing in miraculous ways and kind of my point of kind of bringing some of this up is that like you taking a I'm not necessarily against you know taking a ketamine as a dissociative to get through because I think sometimes you have to punch through that but like I like the how you were you know describing the and like I just trust the you know brain spotting I'll just trust the process and like it works itself out You have to know there's a buying is gonna land and like the what I see when I'm trying to
你知道我们打算怎么做，就像你知道，我不知道，我们只需要能够不质疑科学的存在。心理学在这里有一门科学，定性研究并非一无是处，我们知道的比我们正在做的要多，比医学和我会说法律认为可能的要多。就像我看到治愈以奇迹般的方式发生，我提出其中一些观点的意义在于，你采取……我并不一定反对，你知道，服用氯胺酮作为一种解离剂来度过难关，因为我认为有时你必须冲破它，但我喜欢你描述的方式，我只是信任脑点定位，我只是信任这个过程，它会自行解决。你必须知道会有一个着陆点，就像我试图……时所看到的。
People ask for I'm not a trainer and brain spotting or anything But when people at the clinic or local providers are like can we can we work through some of these is? What you can teach people is that you know I can teach you some kind of tricks that I know or prompts of you you talk enough to get them into the experience and then you stop because you've got the metaphor right and they're experiencing and the people's doing what it's supposed to do. But they need to be let go there. Don't pull them back up in the prefrontal cortex by talking. I can tell a clinician that. But what I see is that if somebody has not done their own work, they don't have faith that that plane will land and the patient starts to go through it, they start to have distress and then the clinician puts the stick down because they don't know. I mean you see things come up especially with DID, especially with dissociation where you just have to say, I know that there's healing on the other side
人们问我……我不是脑点定位的培训师或任何东西，但当诊所或当地的提供者问“我们可以解决其中一些问题吗？”时，你能教人们的是，你知道，我可以教你一些我知道的技巧或提示，你谈论得足够多，让他们进入体验，然后你停止，因为你得到了隐喻，他们正在体验，人们正在做它应该做的事情。但他们需要被放开在那里。不要通过说话把他们拉回到前额叶皮层。我可以告诉临床医生这一点。但我看到的是，如果某人没有做过他们自己的工作，他们就不相信那架飞机能着陆，患者开始经历它，他们开始感到痛苦，然后临床医生就放弃了，因为他们不知道。我的意思是，你会看到一些事情出现，特别是在DID（解离性身份障碍）中，特别是在解离中，你只需要说，我知道在这一过程的另一边有治愈，
of this process but what you're starting to get is real wild. But if somebody hasn't done that themselves, if they haven't been through it, they don't have faith in holding somebody else going through that process You know is that related to what you're saying? Is that is that too much of a side? No, no, I think it's fair and I think that's why we do dual attunement You know within brain spotting and it's not necessarily you know, I mean we highlight it But it's not like almost like required in like EMDR type of things. But no it is required in like EMDR type of things but no it is. Though the dissociative so when we look at to me the cannabinoid system as a way of helping people kind of regulate their alpha compared to like the
但你开始得到的东西真的很疯狂。但如果某人自己没有做过，如果他们没有经历过，他们就没有信心去支持别人经历那个过程。你知道，这和你说的有关吗？这是否太偏离主题了？不，不，我认为这很公平，我认为这就是为什么我们进行双重调谐。你知道，在脑点定位中，它不一定，你知道，我的意思是，我们强调它，但它不像在EMDR类型的事情中几乎是必需的。但不，它在EMDR类型的事情中是必需的，但不，它是。虽然解离……所以当我们看，对我来说，大麻素系统作为一种帮助人们调节他们的Alpha波的方式，相比于像
pain system with the opioid and the that system. I don't know what dissociation means if somebody checks in, if somebody checks out, like they're kind of always has to be a driver unless they're asleep. But even then you have a driver that is, you know, trying to, if they smell the smell of smoke, they're going to wake up. Yeah. You know, and they probably can tell the difference between like, you know, smoking, you know, cigarettes versus like fire smoke. Like it is that tuned. And so these youngest, these youngest parts are often, you know, manifested in, in honestly, evolutionarily, they're, they're manifesting in like a lot of reptilian type of brain type of stuff,
阿片类药物的疼痛系统和那个系统。我不知道解离意味着什么，如果某人进入，如果某人退出，就像他们总是必须有一个驱动者，除非他们睡着了。但即使那样，你也有一个驱动者，你知道，试图，如果他们闻到烟味，他们就会醒来。是的。你知道，他们可能能分辨出，你知道，吸烟，你知道，香烟与火灾烟雾的区别。就像它是那样调谐的。所以这些最年轻的，这些最年轻的部分通常，你知道，体现在，老实说，在进化上，它们体现在，你知道，很多爬行动物类型的大脑类型的东西中，
whether that's metaphorical or whether that's actual. I talked to them as if like rings on a tree, all of these, all the rings of there are here. Like the past is still here. Right. Each year there's a new ring to you. And my line that I say to clients in my, you know, kind of one of my initial things is like, I know I'm not just talking to you today.
无论是隐喻的还是实际的。我和他们交谈，就像树上的年轮，所有这些，所有的年轮都在这里。就像过去仍然在这里。对。每年都有一个新的年轮。我在我的，你知道，我最初的事情之一中对客户说的一句话是，我知道我今天不仅仅是在和你交谈。
I'm talking to every you you've ever been. And if you want to kind of get all spiritual or psychological in a sense, or, uh, uh, you know, future oriented, like, and I'm talking to every you, you'll ever be. Yeah. And so we're in a different space. We're in the, you know, it's a timeless part of the brain. Time stops when you're down there.
我是在和你曾经成为过的每一个你交谈。如果你想变得有点精神或心理上的意义，或者，呃，呃，你知道，面向未来，就像，我是在和你未来将成为的每一个你交谈。是的。所以我们处于一个不同的空间。我们处于，你知道，大脑中一个永恒的部分。当你下到那里时，时间停止了。
If I got somebody into really deep processing back when I was just kind of doing pure brain spotting, if I got somebody into really, especially with one eye closed, the session, they may be processing if they needed a ton, they may be processing really hard for 40 minutes. And when they stopped, they would think that the session had taken however long it was before that moment.
如果我让某人进入非常深的处理，回到我只是在做纯粹的脑点定位的时候，如果我让某人进入，特别是在闭上一只眼睛的情况下，会谈，如果他们需要很多处理，他们可能会非常努力地处理40分钟。当他们停止时，他们会认为会谈在那个时刻之前已经进行了那么久。
If it was 20 minutes to get them down there, they thought that the session was 20 minutes long and they didn't believe me and they were looking at the clock and I was telling them, man, like that part of the brain does not have a clock. And so you were in this timeless part of experience that it has a different clock. It still has a clock.
如果花了20分钟让他们下到那里，他们认为会谈进行了20分钟，他们不相信我，他们看着时钟，我告诉他们，伙计，大脑的那部分没有时钟。所以你处于这种永恒的体验部分，它有一个不同的时钟。它仍然有一个时钟。
It has, it has, it's our circadian rhythms. So Vanderkult gives an example. And the reason why I'll add that to this is because Vanderkult gives an example of a Vietnam vet who goes into a year after, you know, gets discharged and every year, the same day, the same time, down to the same minute, he goes into a convenience store, lights up a cigarette,
它有，它有，它是我们的昼夜节律。所以范德考克（Vanderkolk）给出了一个例子。我把它加到这里的原因是因为范德考克给出了一个越南老兵的例子，他在退伍一年后，每年，同一天，同一时间，精确到同一分钟，他走进一家便利店，点燃一支香烟，
puts his fingers like in his jacket and tries to hold it up. And then the cops get called and he says, you know, he starts to try to draw fire. This happens, you know, however many times, but every year the same time down to the same minute. Yeah. So that's the clock. That's why people get all thrown off because of the circadian rhythms being messed up with the daylight savings times this statistically you are 10 times more likely or whatever the statistic is. I think it's
把手指放在夹克里，试图把它举起来。然后警察被叫来，他说，你知道，他开始试图引火。这种情况发生，你知道，多少次，但每年同一时间，精确到同一分钟。是的。所以这就是时钟。这就是为什么人们因为昼夜节律被夏令时搞乱而感到困惑，统计上你更有可能，或者统计数据是什么。我认为是
a lot more than that to have some type of medical because your body gets thrown off whether or not this car Rex if you want an empirical stat look at the amount of car wrecks that happen the day after daylight savings time You know people are deeply and they're not ready to drive yet You know well the thing that gets to me about it I kind of have a mock campaign on my my YouTube move as to like This is just another example of like you can't follow the science, but they'll make us follow the science Yeah, well and the biomedical model. I, especially when you do QEG brain mapping,
比那多得多，会有某种医疗问题，因为你的身体被搞乱了，无论这是否是车祸，如果你想要一个经验统计数据，看看夏令时之后那天发生的车祸数量。你知道，人们非常……他们还没准备好开车。你知道，好吧，关于这件事让我感到困扰的是，我在我的YouTube上有一个模拟活动，就像这只是另一个例子，你不能遵循科学，但他们会让我们遵循科学。是的，好吧，生物医学模型。我，特别是当你做QEG脑图时，
it's like, even if you accept it based on its own rules, which I think it's always going to be kind of reductive, and we have to have, you know, some kind of framework, you know, you can't completely get rid of something like that. I think it has too much control over clinical work. But even if you accept it on its own terms, and you're like, okay, fine, we have to have an empirical whatever, well, we know with QEG, that if you accept it on its own terms and you're like, okay, fine, we have to have an empirical whatever. Well, we know with QEG that if you have ADHD and you respond to the same symptoms and you take the same medication and respond to, or you have the same symptoms that I can screen for and you take the same medication and you respond to that, when you get under a QEG, ADHD is actually six different things that could be happening in the brain.
就像，即使你基于它自己的规则接受它，我认为它总是会有点还原论，我们必须有，你知道，某种框架，你知道，你不能完全摆脱那样的东西。我认为它对临床工作有太多的控制。但即使你按照它自己的条款接受它，你就像，好吧，没关系，我们必须有某种经验……好吧，我们知道用QEG，如果你按照它自己的条款接受它，你就像，好吧，没关系，我们必须有某种经验……好吧，我们知道用QEG，如果你有ADHD（注意力缺陷多动障碍），并且你对相同的症状有反应，并且你服用相同的药物并有反应，或者你有相同的症状，我可以筛选，你服用相同的药物并对此有反应，当你进入QEG时，ADHD实际上是可能发生在大脑中的六种不同事情。
And if you're doing that screener, You don't know which one it is. So even if you want to say, okay fine biomedical model Let's find these markers and find what's actually going on. Oh, no. No, that's too much work. Okay Well, you don't believe in your own thing at that point. You know what I mean? Like you're saying that you have to Turn these things into an empirically objective Objective thing that you can see and now that we can't the technology is caught up where the clinical wisdom can be Validated empirically they're like no no never mind Exactly exactly Believe what they're saying it's they don't so I said when I did that talk with Van der Kolk and his wife and there's another
如果你在做那个筛选器，你不知道是哪一个。所以即使你想说，好吧，没关系，生物医学模型，让我们找到这些标记并找出到底发生了什么。哦，不。不，那工作量太大了。好吧，那你当时就不相信你自己的东西了。你知道我的意思吗？就像你在说，你必须把这些东西变成一个经验上客观的、你可以看到的东西，现在我们不能了，技术已经赶上了，临床智慧可以在经验上得到验证，他们就像，不，不，没关系。完全正确，完全正确。相信他们正在说的，他们不……所以我说，当我与范德考克和他的妻子进行那次谈话时，还有另一个人在那里，
Person there, too And I said unconscious informed consent and Vanderkulk just laughed and like because I had said it to him before we had met twice and like he was just like he gave me a look of like good luck with that. But like I'm saying I'm like I have a QEG I have a QEG I'm not like I'm not like what more empirical do you want? They're never going to believe it because they don't have necessarily access. And that's how dissociated they may be.
也在那里。我说“无意识知情同意”，范德考克只是笑了，因为我之前在他面前说过，我们见过两次，他就像……他给了我一个眼神，意思是“祝你好运”。但我说，我像……我有一个QEG，我有一个QEG，我不是……我不是……你还想要什么更经验性的东西？他们永远不会相信它，因为他们不一定有获取途径。这就是他们可能有多解离。
And I do take a kind of a stab at like trying to explain this. And one of the brain spotting, there was a brain spotting article that came out in 2022, I believe, December that was calling it a pseudo science. And some of those papers are really wild, though, like there's a guy that published one a year and a half, two years ago, and he wrote basically like he was just like when I was in med school, not even somebody in psych, he just was like, I heard about this brain spotting thing.
我确实尝试解释这一点。在脑点定位中，有一篇脑点定位文章在2022年，我相信是12月出来的，称它为伪科学。但其中一些论文真的很疯狂，就像有一个家伙在一年半、两年前发表了一篇，他写的内容基本上就像……他只是像，当我在医学院时，甚至不是心理学的人，他只是像，我听说过这个脑点定位的东西。
I mean, it's written in academic language, but he's like I heard about this brain-spotting thing That's crazy because when I was in med school in the 80s we know that memory is in the front of the brain and Eye position wouldn't affect that so this thing that I have no experience with or training in is not right And this just goes to show that we should have more better medical training. And it's like where memory is in the brain is one of the most complicated questions in all of modern neuroscience. I mean, somebody could sit down with a medical license and write that and, and that a journal and I don't want to like, I don't want to be too specific here, but like a giant mainstream journal would publish it. I mean, that's why I don't want anything to do
我的意思是，它是用学术语言写的，但他就像，我听说过这个脑点定位的东西。这很疯狂，因为当我在80年代上医学院时，我们知道记忆在大脑的前部，眼睛位置不会影响这一点。所以我没有经验或培训的这个东西是不对的。这恰恰表明我们应该有更好的医学培训。就像记忆在大脑中的位置是现代神经科学中最复杂的问题之一。我的意思是，某人可以拿着行医执照写那个，那个期刊……我不想在这里太具体，但一个巨大的主流期刊会发表它。我的意思是，这就是为什么我个人不想和研究有任何关系。
with research personally. I mean, it's like that. Well, it's getting even kind of uglier, I think, with psychedelics, because the state is actually asking, requiring that people have a license to do research. That is, I'm not talking about like, they're approving the study
我的意思是，它就像那样。好吧，我认为随着迷幻药，它变得更加丑陋，因为国家实际上正在要求，要求人们有执照才能进行研究。这是，我不是在谈论像，他们正在批准这项研究。
Yeah You know and right some of the like, you know opening yourself up to like, you know What is available within the research community for people to be like and this is kind of where I'm going from and I We're not quoting the same article But like at least I don't think we are. But the thing that they're using is APA kind of like systematic, like jargon in my in my book as to be able to weed out what is pseudoscience and what isn't and they're they're they use this word, a phrenia, basically somebody who will pop up for any or something like that, that basically, you'll
是的。你知道，而且，你知道，向研究社区提供什么，让人们像……这就是我正在去的地方，我……我们没有引用同一篇文章。但至少我不认为我们是。但他们正在使用的是APA（美国心理学会）那种系统性的，就像行话，在我的书中，能够剔除什么是伪科学，什么不是，他们使用这个词，“a phrenia”，基本上是某人会为任何事情而跳出来，或者类似的东西，基本上，你
believe whatever I'll tell you like they're like they were, they were calling, you know, brain spotters that. Yeah. And my only question to that is, isn't our do we agree that meditation is evidence based? Like, can we have a common like just or attachment theory, or attachment theory? Sure. And in that developmental trauma exists you know in the grander scheme of things or to my point would be okay so are there other addictions besides you know even though eating disorder isn't really labeled as one but like are there other addictions besides alcohol and drugs and you know gambling are we saying that there's no other addictions out there that are diagnosable?
会相信我告诉你的任何事情，就像他们……他们称，你知道，脑点定位者是那样。是的。我对此的唯一问题是，我们不同意冥想是基于证据的吗？就像，我们可以有一个共同的，就像……或者依恋理论，或者依恋理论？当然。而且在发育创伤确实存在，你知道，在宏大的计划中，或者我的观点是，好吧，那么除了你知道，即使饮食失调并没有真正被标记为一种，除了酒精和药物和你知道，赌博之外，还有其他成瘾吗？我们是在说没有其他可诊断的成瘾吗？
And we do not think that we are part of the social control. So you quoted some people earlier, like I'm sure you probably know Thomas Sazars, Sazars or something like that. I mean like the medical and how this has in the pharmacological and then like to take away the drug that we actually have a healing system and we discovered the cannabinoid system in 2012. And the whole purpose, its whole purpose is for healing. I think it's our immune system. It's the body that keeps the score. And I'll kind of leave on this point. There's a body that keeps the score, and there's a body that knows the score. And if they are one and the same,
而且我们不认为我们是社会控制的一部分。所以你之前引用了一些人，比如我敢肯定你可能知道托马斯·萨兹（Thomas Sazars）或类似的人。我的意思是，医学以及这在药理学上是如何……然后像拿走我们实际上有一个治愈系统的药物，我们在2012年发现了大麻素系统。它的全部目的，它的全部目的就是为了治愈。我认为它是我们的免疫系统。它是记录身体的身体。我会以这一点结束。有一个记录身体的身体，有一个知道记录的身体。如果它们是同一个，
then you know you're kind of like, you know, kind of there. Um, and, you know, past, present and future us, you know, for anybody suffering with dissociation and the, you know, the wounded healers is meant to try and help people kind of find their answers for themselves. And if we can help answer any questions we will, as far as our research, um, I, my, my dissertation is out there for people to read dissociated people are like really interested about going down the rabbit hole of things. I would suggest that because it gives a historical kind of context that you'll start to understand that they sold us that it was a non or
那么你知道你有点像，你知道，有点在那里。嗯，而且，你知道，过去、现在和未来的我们，你知道，对于任何患有解离症的人，以及，你知道，受伤的治疗者，旨在试图帮助人们为自己找到答案。如果我们能帮助回答任何问题，我们会，就我们的研究而言，嗯，我，我的论文在那里供人们阅读，解离的人们对钻进兔子洞的事情真的很感兴趣。我建议这样做，因为它提供了一个历史背景，你会开始明白他们卖给我们说它不是……或者
yeah, they sold us those non-addictive opiate, but they also sold us that it was an abnormal response to an abnormal event. And it took them 15 years to overturn that. And I don't know if we, I don't know if we're still, the other models, if we take a look at what laws we're still following it's from like the 50s yeah so like we're still following a lot of that was just overcorrection from like you know RD Lang and Rosenhan and the the anti-psychiatry movement sort of doing some things that made the establishment look bad and they were like okay well we're gonna take away all the subjective ability of psychiatrists to do this. And we're just going to give you something and treat cognition like it is a computer computer science is emerging now.
是的，他们卖给我们那些非成瘾性阿片类药物，但他们也卖给我们说这是对异常事件的异常反应。他们花了15年才推翻这一点。我不知道我们是否，我不知道我们是否仍然，其他模型，如果我们看看我们仍然遵循的法律，它是从50年代开始的。是的，所以我们仍然遵循很多，那只是过度矫正，来自像，你知道，RD·莱恩（RD Lang）和罗森汉（Rosenhan）以及反精神病学运动，做了一些让机构看起来很糟糕的事情，他们就像，好吧，好吧，我们要拿走精神科医生做这件事的所有主观能力。我们只是要给你一些东西，把认知当作它是一台计算机，计算机科学现在正在兴起。
We're just going to do that. And then, but then they still kept half of the language of, you know, psychoanalysis and psychodynamic therapy and a lot of the Jungian and Fritz Perls and experiential stuff. And it's like, even when you look at that language, and then what happened after the DSM-3, it's like, it doesn't make sense, because, you know, you have two systems
我们只是打算这样做。然后，他们仍然保留了一半的精神分析、动力学疗法以及许多荣格学派、弗里茨·皮尔斯和体验式疗法的术语。就像当你审视这些术语，再看看DSM-3之后发生的事情时，这根本说不通，因为你有两套系统
that are not coming from the same assumptions. It starts to make sense when you need lawyer approval, and it makes sense when you need banking approval, and it makes sense when you need insurance approval. I think that's the only thing, the only places where it makes any sense personally. I mean, I get trying to mitigate, you know, you know, injury and stuff like that,
它们并非基于相同的假设。只有当你需要律师批准、银行批准或保险批准时，这套逻辑才说得通。我认为这是唯一能让它在个人层面讲得通的地方。我的意思是，我理解试图减轻伤害之类的努力，
but my dissertation cautions and or like, you know, highlights that there are three addictions that were missing. And I think that if we were to take an honest, you know, look at the people who took drugs and actually like, you know, found them to be helpful and healing aren't the ones who probably sat in the school and just like did what they were told. Yeah. You know, and that those like, you know, there's no judgment in, you know, people's life choices, but you become aware of things as you get older. If you're keeping the same tradition going that isn't
但我的论文提醒或强调了有三种成瘾被遗漏了。我认为，如果我们诚实地审视那些服用药物并发现它们确实有帮助和疗愈作用的人，他们可能并不是那些坐在学校里只听从指令的人。是的。你知道，人们的生活选择没有对错之分，但随着年龄增长，你会意识到一些事情。如果你继续沿用那些不再
serving you and is developmentally probably immature, perfectionism, altruism, and ambitious addictions makes sense to me. Because that would level the playing field between type A's and type B's. to me because that would level the playing field between type A's and type B's. Well, we'll definitely link to all of your work and is there anything that you want to kind of say to put ahead on the, you know, somebody is saying, well, either I treat addiction or I treat dissociation or I'd like to start to see more of a relationship between these things. Any place that they should go, any place they should look at, you know, we're pretty heavily in the Jungian world but I do think
为你服务且在发展上可能不成熟的传统，那么完美主义、利他主义和雄心勃勃的成瘾对我来说是有意义的。因为这会拉平A型人格和B型人格之间的竞争环境。对我来说，这会拉平A型人格和B型人格之间的竞争环境。好的，我们一定会链接到你的所有作品。你有什么想对那些说“我要么治疗成瘾，要么治疗解离，或者我想开始看到这两者之间更多联系”的人说的吗？他们应该去哪里，应该关注什么？你知道，我们非常深入荣格的世界，但我确实认为
the older depth psychologists, even though they don't tend to be as aware of it, are speaking the same language as these new neurologists and, and, and new kind of neuroinformed and neuro-experiential therapists. But they, a lot of times, those worlds don't overlap a ton. People aren't really aware that there was a tradition doing the same thing before, you know, 1980, basically. aware that there was a tradition doing the same thing before, you know, 1980, basically. Well, I would bring back a couple other traditions within that. I mean, I will go back to the mysticism and William James, Carl Jung, obviously, the collective unconscious and the historical context that I feel like I kind of bring to the table. You know, out of the wounded healers, I realized that like we're missing a profession
老一辈的深度心理学家，尽管他们往往没有那么意识到这一点，但他们说的语言与这些新神经学家以及新一代神经知情和神经体验治疗师是一样的。但很多时候，这些领域并没有太多的重叠。人们并没有真正意识到在1980年之前，基本上就有一种传统在做同样的事情。意识到在1980年之前，基本上就有一种传统在做同样的事情。嗯，我会带回其中的其他几种传统。我的意思是，我会回到神秘主义、威廉·詹姆斯、卡尔·荣格，显然还有集体潜意识，以及我感觉自己带入讨论的历史背景。你知道，作为受伤的疗愈者，我意识到我们缺少一个职业
and that is a healer. And anybody who is like, you know, trained in any trauma resolution, where you've actually got something from your training where you could go back and like take it to the clients, meaning like an intervention, like EMDR, and people could actually like learn or heal in real time type of thing. Like, you quickly realize about how powerful this is, and that like, you're no
那就是疗愈者。任何受过创伤修复训练的人，如果你在训练中确实学到了一些东西，可以回去应用到客户身上，比如像EMDR这样的干预措施，人们实际上可以实时学习或疗愈。你会很快意识到这有多么强大，而且你不再
longer in a therapist role therapy trained you to become a healer. And a healer is somebody who respects the scalpel in that sense. And I think also knows how to journey that too. So people have gone there and come back. And so the Wounded Healers is now creating the profession of healer based on those lineages and also self-help because Bill Wilson was helped by taking a psychedelic. I think those who live experience with these drugs who know how, how they feel and know not necessarily know like, you know, what complications could be with something else. I mean, the organic kind of psychedelics, cannabis, mushroom LSD would be also there because it's in a derivative of your got mold,
处于治疗师的角色，治疗训练让你成为了一名疗愈者。疗愈者是尊重手术刀的人。我认为他们也知道如何引导这种旅程。所以人们去过那里又回来了。因此，“受伤的疗愈者”现在正在基于这些血统以及自助来创造疗愈者这一职业，因为比尔·威尔逊就是通过服用迷幻剂得到帮助的。我认为那些对这些药物有亲身体验的人，知道它们的感觉，不一定知道与其他东西结合会有什么并发症。我的意思是，有机的迷幻剂，大麻、蘑菇、LSD也会在其中，因为它是麦角霉菌的衍生物，
ayahuasca, DMT, these things are all organic organic the processing of them is where we get the problem to me I mean going back to the Salem witch trials the psychedelics have been causing a problem for certain weights of life people eating moldy bread was a Right a problem Yeah, I know that I mean this must have been like huge but you know as far as like, you know The realities of of like, you know some of those things and people tried to start it up pick up on those things but right I mean I think there are people who probably had those you know going for them and knew how to get them and even the mystery traditions illicinian
死藤水、DMT，这些都是有机的，对我来说，加工过程才是问题的所在。我的意思是，回到塞勒姆女巫审判，迷幻剂一直给某些生活方式的人带来问题。人们吃发霉的面包是一个问题。是的，我知道，这一定影响巨大，但就某些事情的现实而言，人们试图开始了解这些事情，但确实，我认为有些人可能确实经历过这些，并且知道如何获得它们，甚至神秘传统，厄琉息斯
mysteries and things a lot of those ritual objects they're finding you know orgots spores that are one of the things that tend not to break down over years you can still test for it right and so and so the Wounded Healers Institute is looking to kind of help people create a community around supporting people through their dissociative process and to give some opportunities for people to highlight the parts, skills, and or have a variety of classes
秘仪之类的东西，他们发现的许多仪式物品中含有麦角孢子，这是多年来不容易分解的东西之一，你仍然可以检测到它。所以，“受伤的疗愈者”研究所正试图帮助人们建立一个社区，围绕支持人们度过解离过程，并提供一些机会让人们突出自己的部分、技能，或者参加各种课程
and support systems in place to help people learn and grow within what I've come to understand. And the healing profession as an opportunity is to kind of bridge the gap between no and yes, no, we need to have a little bit of maybe in our life. Maybe but is your room clean? And yes, no, we need to have a little bit of maybe in our life like maybe but like, you know Is your is your room clean? Right. It is your is your house in order before we start going around telling what other people should do like let's let's Scale it down a little bit too. Like we're all equal and doing the best we can. All right
和支持系统，以帮助人们在我所理解的范围内学习和成长。疗愈职业作为一个机会，是用来弥合“不”和“是”之间的差距，不，我们的生活中可能需要一点“也许”。也许，但你的房间干净吗？是的，不，我们的生活中可能需要一点“也许”，比如也许，但你的房间干净吗？对吧，在开始告诉别人应该做什么之前，你的房子整理好了吗？让我们稍微缩小一下范围。我们都是平等的，都在尽力而为。好的。
Well, and and I think that you have to learn to not hear it and to recognize it for what it is when you get the I think you're just asking really good questions. And that's good food for thought for me to ignore as I learn to recognize that answer for what it is. If you're hearing that, it's an opportunity. That's the ball. I really appreciate your time. We'll definitely link to your website and your work in the show notes. And good luck to you. I'd like to continue this conversation.
嗯，我认为你必须学会不去听它，并在听到时识别出它的本质。我认为你问的问题真的很好。这对我来说是很好的思考素材，当我学会识别那个答案的本质时，我会忽略它。如果你听到了，那是一个机会。这就是重点。我非常感谢你的时间。我们一定会把你的网站和作品链接到节目说明中。祝你好运。我想继续这个对话。
Yeah, same here Joel real pleasure Take care It's what way? underneath the Beneath the bruises you stop The wound is in the story, it's the silence you wrapped around you Healing doesn't mean fixing, it means unfolding Cracking open what was sealed tight just to make it through We spend years avoiding the shadow, but the shadow holds the map. It's not the opposite of your light, it's the root of it. The real change begins not when you become someone new But when you finally stop running from who you've always been I'm going to go ahead and get the This is the work
是的，我也是，乔尔，非常荣幸。保重。是以什么方式？在淤青之下，你停下来。伤口在故事里，是你包裹在自己周围的沉默。疗愈并不意味着修复，它意味着展开。撬开那些为了生存而紧紧密封的东西。我们花了几年的时间逃避阴影，但阴影中藏着地图。它不是你光明的对立面，它是它的根源。真正的改变不是从你变成一个新的人开始的，而是当你终于停止逃避那个一直以来的自己时。我要继续进行，这就是工作。
This is the wild dark miracle Of coming home to yourself There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是回归自我的狂野黑暗奇迹。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。